This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the beginning was the word. And the word was, well actually there was just one word, one long and less word. For thousands of years, text in Europe had no spaces between words. There was nothing at all to guide the reader. That's Keith Houston. He's a returning 99-P.I. guest in author of the book, Shady Characters. So the idea was that the reader would read it aloud and they would have to find the boundaries between words, they would have to work out where sentences and clauses began and ended on their own. Sometimes as never
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。太初有字。而这字，呃，其实只有一个字，一个冗长且不那么……的字。几千年来，欧洲的文本在词与词之间是没有空格的。完全没有任何东西来引导读者。那是基斯·休斯顿。他是《99-P.I.》的老嘉宾，也是《隐秘的符号》一书的作者。所以当时的理念是，读者会大声朗读出来，他们必须自己找出词与词的边界，自己弄清楚句子和分句是从哪里开始，在哪里结束。有时，一个永无
ending string of letters would execute what was called an ox turn. If the first line of text read from left to right, the line below it would read from right to left with the characters themselves drawn and backwards. The point is reading was hard. So there was a librarian at Alexandria, the third century BC, called Aristophanes suggested that readers might want to use little dots, which are very easy to insert between letters, in order to help them remember where the pauses were. The system didn't follow strict rules of grammar. It wasn't about demarcating sentences, but about rhythm. It was initially a kind of stage direction. It was all about the performance of the text.
休止的字母串会采用一种被称为“犁地法”的书写方式。如果第一行文字是从左到右阅读的，那么它下面的一行就会从右到左阅读，字符本身也会被画成反方向的。关键是，阅读很艰难。因此，公元前三世纪，亚历山大图书馆的一位名叫阿里斯托芬的图书管理员建议，读者或许可以试着使用一些小圆点，它们非常容易插入字母之间，以此来帮助他们记住停顿的位置。这个系统并没有遵循严格的语法规则。它不是为了划分句子，而是为了节奏。它最初有点像舞台指导。这完全关乎文本的演绎。
So a point halfway up the line was a very short pause, a point at the bottom of the line was a longer pause, and a point at the top of the line was the longest pause, kind of like a full stop. Aristophanes Little Dots formed the system from which almost all Western punctuation stems. A partial thought, followed by the shortest pause, was called a comma. A fuller thought was called a colon, and a complete thought, a period. A period. More punctuation followed. Medieval scribes gave us the earliest forms of the exclamation mark.
所以，行中高处的一个点表示非常短的停顿，行底的一个点表示较长的停顿，而行顶的一个点表示最长的停顿，有点像句号。阿里斯托芬的小圆点构成了几乎所有西方标点符号都源自的系统。一个不完整的想法，后面跟着最短的停顿，被称为逗号。一个更完整的想法被称为冒号，而一个完整的想法，则被称为句号。一个句号。更多的标点符号随之出现。中世纪的抄写员为我们带来了感叹号的最早雏形。
And in the 8th century, Al-Quen of York, an English scholar in the Court of Charlemagne, quietly introduced a symbol that would evolve into the modern question mark. Ever since, we've ended our sentences with one of these three marks. Question mark, period, exclamation point. They're called end marks. It's an exclusive club, and really hard to break into. That's 99PI producer Joe Rosenberg.
在8世纪，查理曼大帝宫廷的英国学者约克的阿尔昆，悄悄引入了一个符号，它后来演变成了现代的问号。从那以后，我们的句子总是以这三个符号之一结尾。问号、句号、感叹号。它们被称为句末点。这是一个专属俱乐部，而且极难加入。那是《99PI》的制作人乔·罗森伯格。
But today, the story of a punctuation mark that almost managed to join this exclusive cabal of three. In the new Miriam Webster's Collegiate Dictionary, the 11th edition, there it is listed among the various punctuation marks, the interibang. This is Penny Specter, and the mark she's talking about, the interibang, it's a real thing. You could use it right now if you wanted to, but it's still just a baby mark of punctuation. The story of its invention and what it is exactly begins just a little over 50 years ago,
但今天，我们要讲述的是一个差一点就成功加入这个由三个成员组成的专属小圈子的标点符号的故事。在最新版的《梅里厄姆-韦伯斯特大学词典》第11版中，它赫然在列，在各种标点符号中列出——这就是疑问感叹号（interrobang）。这是彭尼·斯佩克特，而她所说的这个符号，即疑问感叹号，是真实存在的。如果你愿意，你现在就可以使用它，但它依然只是一个标点符号界的婴儿。它的发明故事以及它到底是什么，要从五十多年前说起，
with Penny's late husband, Martin Spector. You could say Martin was an idea man. He worked in advertising. And if you're picturing the life of a New York ad executive filled with cocktails, like brain storming and Madison Avenue glamour, go right ahead. In the 1950s and 60s Martin wrapped some of the biggest names in publishing, such as barons, dow Jones, and the Wall Street Journal. And we ate dinner out most evenings and Martin got some of his best ideas, just jotted down in the backs of Olden, Velopes as everybody did.
故事的主人公是彭尼已故的丈夫马丁·斯佩克特。你可以说马丁是一个充满点子的人。他从事广告工作。如果你脑海中浮现出纽约广告高管的生活，充满鸡尾酒、头脑风暴和麦迪逊大道的魅力，那就尽管想象吧。在20世纪50年代和60年代，马丁为出版业的一些最大巨头处理过业务，比如巴伦周刊、道琼斯和《华尔街日报》。我们几乎每天晚上都在外面吃晚餐，马丁的一些最好的灵感，就像大家常做的那样，只是随手记在旧信封的背面。
But Martin wasn't in it for the glamour. He loved design, and he was a typography nut. Martin was constantly reading books on punctuation, on typography, on English, you, Siege, and so forth. And when he died, we had a separate apartment with about 250 small printing presses. Oh my god. Yeah, some of them this high, some of them this high, and then we had a really big one which
但马丁可不是为了追求光鲜亮丽才做这个的。他热爱设计，是个排版狂热爱好者。马丁一直在阅读关于标点符号、排版、英语、用法等方面的书籍。他去世时，我们有一间单独的公寓，里面大约有250台小型印刷机。哦，天哪。是的，有些这么高，有些这么高，然后我们还有一个非常大的，
took a full page newspaper. And do you actually have any presses left? Yeah, I have about 20 of them. She's still 20, see that still. Still like a huge number of them. I know, but they're little. It was at this intersection of typographical nursery and Madison Avenue moxie that Martin K. Specter had his big idea.
可以印一整版报纸。那你现在还留着任何印刷机吗？是的，我大约还留着20台。她依然留着20台，看到没，依然。依然有这么庞大的数量。我知道，但它们都很小。正是在这种排版苗圃与麦迪逊大道精明干练的交汇点上，马丁·K·斯佩克特萌生了他的伟大想法。
It was the spring of 1962. This was the golden age of the advertising slogan. And Martin noticed something that's still true today, that advertisements. Mr. Owl. Or a wash. How many licks does it take to get you to the 20-year-old center of a Tootsie bar? In questions.
那是1962年的春天。这是广告标语的黄金时代。马丁注意到一个至今依然成立的事实，那就是广告……猫头鹰先生。还是……一颗糖？吃完一颗图茨爵士棒的中心需要舔多少次？……是以疑问句的形式呈现的。
Can you hear me now? Can you hear me now? Can you hear me now? God, milk. And not just any questions, but excited questions, exclamatory questions. Questions like... Wesson! Wesson! WessEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE without placing question marks and exclamation points back to back. Spectre saw that in this case, the ancient model of reading still held.
你现在能听到我说话吗？你现在能听到我说话吗？你现在能听到我说话吗？天哪，牛奶。而且不仅仅是普通的疑问句，而是激动的疑问句，感叹式的疑问句。像这样的疑问句……Wesson！Wesson！WessEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE……却无法将问号和感叹号背靠背地放在一起。斯佩克特发现，在这种情况下，古代的阅读模式依然适用。
If you wrote an exclamatory question, the reader was still expected to work out the nature of the sentence through context, not punctuation. Then we were having dinner one night when he came up with a solution for it. The interrebang. Spectre was the editor of a typography magazine called Type Talks. And in the March, April 1962 issue, in an article titled Making a New Point, or How About That, he proposed the first new end mark in the English language in 300 years. With the Interro Bang, Spectre collapsed the question mark and the exclamation point into
如果你写了一个感叹式的疑问句，读者仍然需要通过上下文来琢磨句子的性质，而不是靠标点符号。然后有一天我们在吃晚餐时，他想出了一个解决方案。疑问感叹号（interrobang）。斯佩克特曾是一本名为《Type Talks》的排版杂志的编辑。在1962年3月/4月号上，在一篇题为《创造一个新标点，或者觉得这怎么样》的文章中，他提出了300年来英语中的第一个新句末标点。通过疑问感叹号，斯佩克特将问号和感叹号融合成
a single glyph. The two marks instead of being placed placed back to back, were now conjoined, sharing the same dot at the bottom of the line, with the sharp vertical slash of the exclamation point nestled inside the sinuous curve of the question mark. The inter-bang means exactly what it looks like. It notes a question that expresses surprise or incredulity. This also makes it useful for rhetorical questions, most of which are it turns out also incredulous. In his article, Spectre was already envisioning exclamatory slash rhetorical advertising slogans that could take advantage of this new mark, such as what a refrigerator that makes its own ice cubes, although
了一个单一的字形。这两个符号没有背靠背地放置，而是结合在了一起，共享行底部的同一个圆点，感叹号尖锐的垂直斜线嵌套在问号优美的曲线之中。疑问感叹号的意思和它的外表完全一样。它表示一个表达惊讶或怀疑的疑问句。这也使得它非常适合用于修辞疑问句，事实证明，大多数修辞疑问句也带有怀疑色彩。在文章中，斯佩克特已经在构想可以利用这个新符号的感叹式/修辞式广告标语，比如，竟然有能自己做冰块的电冰箱，尽管
penny prefers. Who forgot to put gas in the car? Which is not really a question. Hahaha. Spectre provided a few alternate designs for the intero-bang. And readers of Type Talks also wrote in with proposals for alternate names, including AnthoQuest, InteroPoint, and my personal favorite, X-Clarogative. Well, I like that one.
彭尼更喜欢：谁忘了往车里加油？这其实并不是一个问题。哈哈。斯佩克特为疑问感叹号提供了几种备选设计。《Type Talks》的读者也写信提出了其他名称的建议，包括AnthoQuest、InteroPoint，以及我个人最喜欢的X-Clarogative。嗯，我喜欢那个。
Let's use that one. Sorry, Roman, they didn't go with that one. Spectre's original name stuck in TerraBang. In TerraB for Interrogate and Bang for the proofreaders word for the exclamation point. Traditionally, printers didn't use the term exclamation point. If you're reading copy with somebody, you're never going to say exclamation point,
咱们就用那个吧。抱歉，罗曼，他们没有选那个。斯佩克特最初起的名字保留了下来——InterroBang（疑问感叹号）。Interro代表Interrogate（询问），Bang是校对员对感叹号的称呼。传统上，印刷工不使用“感叹号”这个词。如果你和某人一起校对文稿，你绝不会说“感叹号”，
just say bang. But when he came up with the idea, and you talked about it together, how serious was he? Oh, he was very serious. And he really thought that people in advertising would hook on to it. So what happened to Spectre's invention? If it really is in the dictionary, effectively waiting to be used, why haven't we seen more
只会说“bang”。但是当他想出这个点子时，你们一起讨论过，他有多认真？哦，他非常认真。而且他真的认为广告界的人会喜欢上它。那么斯佩克特的发明后来怎么样了？如果它真的被收录在词典里，实际上正等待着被使用，为什么我们没怎么见过
in tarot banks? It's not easy to invent a mark of punctuation that actually sticks. That's Keith Houston again, and to be clear, Keith loves the in tarot bank. He's rooting for it, so it pains him to say this, but it turns out that inventing a successful mark of punctuation, particularly in N Mark, is really hard. History is filled with far more attempts at creating new marks. Pretty much all of which have failed. In a round about the 16th century, the percundation mark, this rhetorical question mark, last about 50 years before it disappeared.
疑问感叹号呢？发明一个真正能流传下来的标点符号可不容易。这是基斯·休斯顿再次发言，需要说明的是，基斯非常喜欢疑问感叹号。他在为之加油，所以说出这话让他感到心痛，但事实证明，发明一个成功的标点符号，尤其是句末标点，真的很难。历史上充满了更多创造新标点的尝试。几乎所有这些尝试都失败了。大约在16世纪左右，反问号（percundation mark），这个修辞问号，在消失之前大约持续了50年。
There's irony mark invented by a kind of Renaissance man called John Wilkins who had proposed an inverted exclamation mark and it went nowhere. And then there's the interrobe, which seemingly from the day it was born, faced a string of bad luck. For example, an article praising the interrobe appeared in the New York Carol Tribune in 1962, after the writer at Red Martin's original piece in type talks. In the Tribune article, the writer called the intero-bang true genius. But unfortunately, his article was published on the 1st of April, and readers may have took it as an April Fools joke. So there's that little blip.
还有由一位名叫约翰·威尔金斯的文艺复兴式全才发明的讽刺号（irony mark），他曾提议使用一个倒过来的感叹号，但它最终不了了之。然后还有疑问感叹号（interrobang），似乎从它诞生的第一天起，就遭遇了一连串的好运不济。例如，一篇赞美疑问感叹号的文章于1962年在《纽约先驱论坛报》上发表，此前该报的撰稿人阅读了马顿在《Type Talks》上的原创文章。在这篇《论坛报》文章中，作者称疑问感叹号为真正的天才。但不幸的是，他的文章发表在4月1日，读者们可能把它当成了一个愚人节玩笑。所以，这就是一个小插曲。
Still our baby punctuation marked persevered. In 1966 a company called the American Type Founders, a legendary design firm that created some of the most widely used typefaces of the 20th century, unveiled a new typeface called Americana that included an Interro bag. And then the company slowly went bust. Americana was the last font they actually cut, and so they did not cut anymore in TerroBanks. But all was not lost.
尽管如此，我们这个初生的标点符号还是坚持了下来。1966年，一家名为美国铅字铸造公司（American Type Founders）的传奇设计公司——该公司创造了20世纪一些使用最广泛的字体——推出了一种名为Americana的新字体，其中就包含了一个疑问感叹号。然后这家公司就慢慢破产了。Americana是他们实际雕刻的最后一款字体，因此他们再也没有雕刻过更多的疑问感叹号。但并不是一切都失去了。
In the year 1968, the iconic typewriter company Remington announced that their latest model typewriter would feature an optional in TerroBank key. But I wonder if perhaps the fact that you had to pay some extra money to get an in terobank key might have turned people off. Today, the in terobank is just barely hanging in there. The mark is recognized by websters, just like Penny said, and it is included in a surprising number of computer fonts.
在1968年，标志性的打字机公司雷明顿（Remington）宣布，他们最新型号的打字机将配备一个可选的疑问感叹号键。但我想，也许是因为你必须支付额外的费用才能买到一个疑问感叹号键，这件事可能把人们吓退了。如今，疑问感叹号只是勉强维持着存在。正如彭尼所说，这个符号得到了韦伯斯特词典的认可，并且它被收录在数量惊人的计算机字体中。
It even has its own character in Unicode, the common directory of symbols which all computer fonts must reference. But Keith points out that it still hasn't cleared the biggest typographical hurdle of all. I think that to consider it to be a real mark of punctuation, people have to use it without thinking about it. In other words, a truly remarkable mark of punctuation must be unremarkable. It must be banal. And banality is not one of the interobeying strong suits.
它甚至在统一码（Unicode）中有自己的字符，而统一码是所有计算机字体都必须参考的通用符号目录。但基斯指出，它依然没有跨越最大的排版障碍。我认为要把它视为一个真正的标点符号，人们必须在不假思索的情况下使用它。换句话说，一个真正杰出的标点符号必须是毫不起眼的。它必须是平庸的。而平庸并不是疑问感叹号的强项。
After Remington's brief attempt to give it a key, it never made it onto any standard keyboards. And now, if it is included in a font, it's accessible only with an inestated series of menus and selections. So when people do use it, they're deliberately going out of their way to do so. They're using it because it's fun, not because it's needed. Keith has gone on to document ever more outlandish examples of the intero-bang, which have, perversely, only made it stand out more, further undermining its legitimacy.
在雷明顿短暂尝试为其添加一个按键之后，它就再也没有进入任何标准键盘。现在，如果它被包含在某个字体中，只能通过一系列嵌套的菜单和选项才能访问它。因此，当人们使用它时，他们是刻意绕道而行才这么做的。他们使用它是觉得好玩，而不是因为需要。基斯接着记录了更多关于疑问感叹号的奇葩例子，这些例子反而适得其反，让它更加显眼，进一步削弱了它的合法性。
A quick Facebook search yields at least two bands named Intero-bang, one punk, one brass. In 2014, an Australian cartographer in the state of Victoria painted an InteroBang on the roof of his house. It's now visible on Google Maps. And in 2017, the Minneapolis Star Tribune ran an obituary for the poet J. Otis Powell, who had always ended his name with an exclamation point, but changed it to an InteroBang before his death. None of these examples are in the service of an exclamatory question.
在Facebook上快速搜索一下，至少能找到两个以“Interrobang”命名的乐队，一个朋克乐队，一个铜管乐队。2014年，维多利亚州的一位澳大利亚制图师在他家的屋顶上画了一个疑问感叹号。现在在谷歌地图上还能看到它。2017年，《明尼阿波利斯明星论坛报》为诗人J·奥蒂斯·鲍威尔刊登了一则讣告，他的名字总是以感叹号结尾，但在去世前，他将感叹号改成了疑问感叹号。这些例子都不是为了表达感叹式的疑问。
They're there to be noticed. You do sometimes see it on Twitter. Someone will ask a question and terminate it with an entero bank. But then they'll stick in hash, entero bank, just to make sure that you've got the joke, that you've absolutely saw what they were doing. So the banality isn't there yet, it still stands out. And for Keith, this is the brass ring of punctuation,
它们出现是为了引人注目。你有时确实会在Twitter上看到它。有人会问一个问题，并以疑问感叹号结尾。但随后他们会加上标签#interrobang，只是为了确保你懂这个梗，确保你绝对看出了他们在做什么。所以那种平庸感还不存在，它依然十分显眼。对基斯来说，这是标点符号界的至高荣耀，
for ordinary people to employ the intero-bang, for no other reason, beyond the fact that the sentence at hand calls for its use. Maybe then we can say that it's made it, maybe then we can say that it's made it. Maybe then we can say that it's a real market punctuation. This left me with only one question. Have you ever seen any truly earnest, truly banal in terabangs in the wild, so to speak? Who knows?
即普通人在使用疑问感叹号时，没有别的原因，纯粹是因为当下的句子需要它。也许到了那个时候，我们才能说它成功了，也许到了那个时候，我们才能说它成功了。也许到了那个时候，我们才能说它是一个真正的标点符号。这只留给我一个问题。你有没有在野外——可以这么说——见过任何真正真诚、真正平庸的疑问感叹号？谁知道呢？
Terabangs could be lurking in an unself conscious way, in books, in newspapers, perhaps we just don't know about it, perhaps it's flying under the radar at the moment. However, I told Keith I might know of at least one genuinely in all in terobang. Because it turns out there's this guy. I'm Frankie Easterbrook. He's a judge. Chief Judge of the United States Court of Appeals for the Seventh Circuit. Oh, he totally sounds like a judge.
疑问感叹号可能正以一种毫不在意的方式潜伏在书籍中、报纸里，也许我们只是不知道，也许它目前正处于雷达监测不到的地方。不过，我告诉基斯，我可能知道至少一个真正无意中使用的疑问感叹号。因为事实证明，有这么一个人。我是弗兰基·伊斯特布鲁克（Frankie Easterbrook）。他是一位法官。美国联邦第七巡回上诉法院的首席法官。哦，他听起来完全就像个法官。
And he's kind of a big deal. The Court of Appeals is the second highest court in the land. And before that, I was deputy solicitor general of the United States. The solicitor general's office is the office that argues the interest of the United States in the Supreme Court. And just like Martin K. Specter, the chief interest of the United States in the Supreme Court. And just like Martin K. Specter, the chief judge for the United States Court of Appeals for the Seven Circuit is a type file.
而且他相当有分量。上诉法院是美国国内仅次于最高法院的第二高法院。在此之前，我是美国副副总检察长（deputy solicitor general）。副总检察长办公室是负责在最高法院陈述美国利益的办公室。正如马宁·K·斯佩克特一样，美国联邦第七巡回上诉法院的首席法官也是一个排版狂热者。
Because when I started reading, I noticed that some things were easier to read than others. And I started looking in the back of the books because there would be a line on the last page saying, this book is sat in and would then name the typeface and who designed the typeface. And that's stuck with me ever since. And now God helped the lawyer who submits a brief
因为当我开始阅读时，我注意到有些东西比其他东西更容易阅读。我开始查看书的背面，因为最后一页上会有一行字写着：“本书排版采用……”然后会列出字体名称以及是谁设计了这种字体。这从那时起就一直印在我的脑海里。如今，如果有律师敢向
to Easterbrook's court in Times New Roman. The default font of our Times does not fly in the 7th Circuit. No, it doesn't. We strongly discourage Times New Roman. The reason why Times New Roman has been a plague is that Times New Roman is a newspaper typeface. We want lawyers to use walker type faces. And so the national rule of a pellet procedure 32, which I actually wrote. The point is, Easterbrook, he knows things, esoteric things. And he's a stickler.
伊斯特布鲁克的法庭提交一份使用Times New Roman字体的简报，那可真是在拿上帝开玩笑。我们这个时代默认的字体在第七巡回法院行不通。不，确实行不通。我们强烈不鼓励使用Times New Roman。Times New Roman之所以成为一场瘟疫，是因为Times New Roman是一种报纸字体。我们希望律师们使用书籍字体。因此，联邦上诉程序规则第32条，其实是我写的。关键是，伊斯特布鲁克，他懂得很多，都是些冷门的知识。而且他是个一丝不苟的人。
In his courtroom, there's a proper place and use for everything. And in May of 2011, Easterbrook was writing a ruling for a case, the case of Sears versus Crowley. When he realized he'd written himself into a corner. I reached a point where I had written a rhetorical question in the opinion where I was tempted to use, you know, a question mark, exclamation point, question mark, exclamation point. And for a moment, he considered changing the sentence, just to avoid the indignity of putting
在他的法庭上，万物皆有其恰当的位置和用途。2011年5月，伊斯特布鲁克正在为一个案件撰写判决书，即西尔斯诉克劳利案（Sears v. Crowley）。当他意识到自己把文章写进了一个死胡同里。我达到了这样一个地步：我在意见书中写了一个修辞疑问句，当时我很想使用，你知道的，问号、感叹号、问号、感叹号。有一会儿，他考虑过修改句子，仅仅为了避免把所有这些符号背靠背放在一起的有失体面的做法，尽管他知道这会削弱他的论点的说服力。
all those marks back to back, even though he knew it would make his argument less compelling. But then, Judge Frank Easterbrook remembered something, an obscure mark of punctuation that would allow him to keep the sentence in all its rhetorical glory, just as it was. So, out came the interrebang. Jackpot. What better place for an unself-conscious interrebang to appear than the actual jurisprudence of the American legal system? Not that anyone was around to appreciate it at the time. Most people at court assumed it was a printing error. And of course, my clerks had this reaction when they saw it. They said, gee, there must be some garble here.
但随后，弗兰克·伊斯特布鲁克法官想起了一件事——一个晦涩难懂的标点符号，可以让他在保留句子所有修辞光彩的同时，原封不动地保留它。于是，疑问感叹号登场了。中头彩。对于一个自然而然出现的疑问感叹号来说，还有什么地方比美国法律体系的实际司法裁决更合适的呢？并不是说当时有人在场去欣赏它。法庭上的大多数人都以为这是一个印刷错误。当然，我的书记员看到它时也是这个反应。他们说，天哪，这里一定有什么地方印乱了。
What happened? And I told them, no, this is a real character. It's called an interrebang. And they both immediately looked it up on Wikipedia, where it has its own entry. Easterbrook slits in tarot bang into a dense paragraph of legalese. I actually had to read the entire eight-page opinion to make sure that he used it correctly. The sentence defies summary.
怎么回事？我告诉他们，不，这是一个真正的字符。它叫做疑问感叹号（interrobang）。他们俩立刻在维基百科上查了查，上面有它自己的词条。伊斯特布鲁克将疑问感叹号滑入了一段密集的法律术语段落中。我实际上不得不阅读了全部八页的判决书，以确保他正确使用了它。这个句子无法概括。
But what I can tell you is that, to the everlasting joy of Keith Houston, the deployment of the tarot Bang is extremely banal. It's just so matter of fact, it's just it's just in there. There are you know pages before it and pages after it, there's nothing to say, hey look, I've just used an Interro Bang. Which only gives Easterbrook's Interro Bang even more authenticity. He clearly wasn't showing off, nor has he publicized it in any way since. But still, I had to administer one last test. Were you kind of like chomping at the bit to use it, were you like, man, I just can't wait for an opportunity
但我能告诉你的是，令基斯·休斯顿感到无限欣喜的是，疑问感叹号的使用是极其平庸的。它是如此的就事论事，它就那么……就那么呆在里面。你知道的，它前面有好几页，后面也有好几页，没有什么东西在喊着“嘿，看呐，我刚刚用了一个疑问感叹号”。这反而赋予了伊斯特布鲁克的疑问感叹号更多的真实性。他显然不是在炫耀，事后也没有以任何方式进行宣传。不过，我还是得进行最后一次测试。你当时是不是有点像迫不及待地想用它，你是不是觉得，天哪，我简直等不及要找个机会
for like a kind of, no? No, I wasn't chomping at the bit to use it. Were you planning on using it again? If the occasion arises. Shortly after Easterbrook issued his opinion, his quiet, use of an obscure form of punctuation was spotted by a legal block and added to the Interrobangs Wikipedia page. When we told Easterbrook this, he laughed. He said he never intended to draw attention to the Interrobang.
来用一下……没有吗？没有，我并没有迫不及待地想用它。你打算再次使用它吗？如果机会合适的话。在伊斯特布鲁克发布判决书后不久，他悄悄使用这种晦涩标点符号的行为被一个法律博客发现了，并被添加到了疑问感叹号的维基百科页面上。当我们把这件事告诉伊斯特布鲁克时，他笑了。他说他从未打算引起人们对疑问感叹号的注意。
He just thought it was the right mark to use. From a typographic character, you don't see all that much, to one that you may be seeing all too often. We revisit the story of the Octathorp after this. Like the Antaro Bang, the Octathorp, also known as the Hashmark or the Pound Sign, is a special character that existed for a long time on the periphery of punctuation. But unlike the Interro Bang, the Octa Thorpe took off and became something we use every day thanks to new technologies.
他只是觉得那是当时该使用的正确符号。从一个你不太常见到的排版字符，到一个你可能见得过于频繁的字符。接下来，我们将重新探讨“井号”（Octothorp）的故事。就像疑问感叹号一样，“井号”——也被称为数字键或磅号——是一个长期存在于标点符号边缘的特殊字符。但与疑问感叹号不同的是，“井号”由于新技术的出现而腾飞，成为了我们每天都在使用的东西。
Here's the story of the Octa Thorpe. It was originally released in December 2014. Every morning I wake up, roll over, pick up my phone, and check Twitter. Not proud of this, it's just the way it is. Twitter always struck me as the social media platform that was the most like broadcasting. It's an ongoing global conversation you can jump into, get a sense of what's going on in the world, and jump out. It's a lot like scanning through a radio dial, but it's mainly comprised of people you know and the people they know, telling you about their day, reacting to shocking
这就是“井号”的故事。它最初于2014年12月发布。每天早上我醒来，翻个身，拿起手机，查看Twitter。对此我并不感到骄傲，事实就是如此。Twitter一直给我一种社交媒体平台的印象，它最像是广播。这是一个你可以随时加入的进行中的全球对话，了解世界上正在发生的事情，然后离开。这很像在收音机频段里扫描，但它主要由你认识的人以及他们认识的人组成，他们向你讲述他们的日常，对令人震惊的
news, making jokes, and sending around links. I tweeted Roman Mars by the way if you haven't heard me say that before. And sometimes I tweet at Truffleman, because this producer's name is Avery Truffleman. But if you want to find out about the show in general, there's a hashtag for it. It's hashtag 999PI. The hashtag, of course, is comprised of two vertical lines intersecting two horizontal lines that looks like a tic-tac-toe board. In the current digital world, the hashtag identifies movements, events, happenings, brands,
新闻做出反应，开玩笑，并四处发送链接。顺便说一句，如果你们以前没听过我这么说的话，我发了一条@罗曼·马斯的推文。有时我也会发@特鲁夫曼，因为这位制作人的名字叫艾弗瑞·特鲁夫曼。但如果你想了解关于这个节目的整体情况，有一个专门的标签。那就是#99PI。这个标签当然由两条垂直线和两条水平线相交组成，看起来像一个井字棋盘。在当前的数字世界中，标签（hashtag）识别着各种运动、活动、大事件、品牌、
topics of all kinds. Hashtags help people gather. That's incredible power to give to individuals. And as a character, I mean awesome. It's got this little typographic superhero story now. And this superhero story, stars Chris Messina. I'm Chris Messina, the inventor of the hashtag. I'm a designer and translator.
各种主题。标签帮助人们聚集在一起。赋予个人这种力量是不可思议的。作为一个字符，我的意思是太棒了。它现在拥有了这个小小的排版超级英雄故事。而这个超级英雄故事的主角是克里斯·梅西纳（Chris Messina）。我是克里斯·梅西纳，标签（hashtag）的发明者。我是一名设计师和翻译。
Translator? A human culture. That's probably a little bit bloated. I don't know. I don't know what I culture. That's probably a little bit bloated. I don't know. I don't know what I do. Chris was the first one to use a hashtag on Twitter before it was even called a hashtag. Back in August of 2007, when he was going to an event called BarCamp.
翻译？人类文化的翻译。那可能有点夸大其词了。我不知道。我不知道我在做什么文化。那可能有点夸大其词了。我不知道。我不知道我在做什么。克里斯是在Twitter上第一个使用标签（hashtag）的人，当时甚至还不叫标签。早在2007年8月，当他要去参加一个名为BarCamp的活动时。
It's an nerdy thing. It's an event that you go to that's completely unstructured and unplanned and the participants figure it out. So the participants needed a way of organizing, which led Chris to tweet the very first hashtag, even though at that point it was just a pound sign. How do you guys feel about using pound barcamp for groups? Putting a pound sign in front of the word barcamp helps the other people at barcamp pick out the word barcamp in their Twitter stream and encourages all the other barcamp participants to use the word barcamp in their Twitter stream and encourages all the other barcamp participants
这是一个极客风格的活动。这是一个完全无结构、无计划的活动，由参与者自己摸索。因此，参与者需要一种组织方式，这促使克里斯发出了有史以来的第一条带标签的推文，尽管当时它还只是一个磅号。大家觉得用“#barcamp”来作为群组标识怎么样？在“barcamp”这个词前面加上一个磅号，可以帮助barcamp的其他人在他们的Twitter信息流中挑出“barcamp”这个词，并鼓励所有其他的barcamp参与者在他们的推文中
to use the word barcamp in their tweets. So now everyone who's interested in barcamp can search for that term and join the conversation. Now let's hope I never have to use the word barcamp again. So some people got on board and agreed to use the pound sign. But most were like, okay, you go do that. The pound symbol had already pervaded other corners of the web.
使用“barcamp”这个词。这样，所有对barcamp感兴趣的人都可以搜索该词并加入对话。现在希望我永远不必再使用“barcamp”这个词了。因此，有些人加入了进来，同意使用这个磅号。但大多数人则觉得，好吧，你自己去弄吧。磅号当时已经渗透到了网络的其他角落。
Internet Relay Chat, aka IRC, used the pound sign to represent chat rooms or conversation channels. There was another social network at the time called Jiku that also had these channels. So there was other stuff that came before me. But Chris was using bunches of pound signs throughout his tweets.
互联网中继聊天（Internet Relay Chat，简称IRC）使用磅号来表示聊天室或对话频道。当时还有另一个名为Jiku的社交网络也有这些频道。所以在我之前还有其他东西。但克里斯在他的推文中到处都在使用一堆磅号。
I was putting pound symbols in front of my words, and people were like, I don't understand what you're doing. You're putting all the strange punctuation in front of your stuff, and it looks dumb. But the true believers stood by the sign. One Twitter user called it a hash tag, because hash is the British name for the sign, and these were being used as category tags. And then the hash and the tag got conjoined into one word. Chris actually brought the hashtag idea
我在我的词前面加上磅号，人们就说，我搞不懂你在干什么。你在你的东西前面加上所有这些奇怪的标点符号，这看起来太蠢了。但真正的信徒们坚定地支持这个符号。一个Twitter用户称它为一个“hash tag”（哈希标签），因为hash是这个符号的英国名称，而这些符号正被用作分类标签。然后“hash”和“tag”结合成了一个词。克里斯实际上把标签的想法直接带到了
to Twitter headquarters directly, but they thought it would never catch on. It looked clunky. Then a few months later in October of 2007, the purpose of the hashtag was fully realized. A friend of mine was down in San Diego, his name's Nate Ritter, and he was using Twitter, basically pulling all this stuff together
Twitter总部，但他们认为这永远不会流行起来。它看起来很笨拙。几个月后，即2007年10月，标签的用途得到了充分体现。我的一个朋友在圣迭戈，他叫内特·里特（Nate Ritter），他在使用Twitter，基本上把关于圣迭戈发生的这些火灾的所有信息
around these fires that were going on in San Diego. Wildfires were raging around San Diego, and residents were tracking the spread through Nate Ritter's tweets. But he was prefixing all of his tweets with San's base Diego space fire. So Chris told Nate that he should switch to hashtag San Diego Fire, all one word, and then other users would imitate him. And it worked. People trying to find out about the fire knew exactly where to look on Twitter.
汇集到一起。野火在圣迭戈周围肆虐，居民们通过内特·里特的推文追踪火灾的蔓延情况。但他所有的推文都以“San（空格）Diego（空格）fire”开头。于是克里斯告诉内特，他应该改用“#SanDiegoFire”，全连在一起，然后其他用户就会模仿他。这真的奏效了。那些试图了解火灾的人确切地知道在Twitter上的什么地方寻找。
And this was the moment where everyone went, oh, that's what these signs are for. Now to clarify, hashtags weren't a thing that Twitter planned on. And they kind of dragged their feet on incorporating it. We kept thinking there must be a better way to organize all this information that's flying through Twitter. We kept looking for it, we never really found it. But the hashtag and retrospect was just this obvious tool. Andy Lorich, then an employee at Twitter, officially brought in the hashtag.
这就是每个人都恍然大悟的时刻，哦，原来这些符号是这个用途。需要澄清的是，标签并不是Twitter计划要搞的东西。他们对将其纳入功能显得有些拖延。我们一直认为，一定有一种更好的方式来组织所有这些在Twitter上飞速流转的信息。我们一直在寻找，但从未真正找到。但回想起来，标签只是这样一个显而易见的工具。安迪·洛里奇（Andy Lorich），当时是Twitter的一名员工，正式引入了标签。
The users brought in the hashtag. What all I did was link the hashtag to Twitter search. One line of code took me about 15 seconds, didn't really ask anybody. That one line of code meant that when you clicked on a word with a hashtag in front of it, you'd see a page with all the other tweets that also contained that hashtag word. And basically, this helped you round up everyone who was talking about a specific topic.
是用户引入了标签。我所做的全部事情就是把标签链接到Twitter的搜索功能。一行代码，花了我大约15秒钟，也没怎么问任何人。那一行代码意味着，当你点击一个前面带有标签的单词时，你会看到一个页面，上面显示了所有其他包含该标签单词的推文。基本上，这帮助你把所有谈论特定主题的人都汇集到了一起。
And now the hashtag is a tool used in advertisements, social movements, music videos, memes, TV shows. And in conversation, hashtag sometimes. Even Chris acknowledges how irritating this is. It's getting to the point where the hashtag is erasing the symbols other uses. A friend of mine actually sent me a tweet the other day saying that he is delivery guy showed up and was looking for a hashtag 2A. Though I'd hope that most people who make deliveries for a living hashtag SMH
现在，标签已经成为了广告、社会运动、音乐视频、表情包、电视节目中使用的工具。在日常对话中，有时也会说“hashtag（加个标签）”。甚至连克里斯也承认这有多么令人恼火。现在情况发展到这样的地步：标签正在抹去这个符号的其他用途。我的一位朋友前几天甚至发给我一条推特，说他的送货员出现并正在寻找“hashtag 2A（标签2A）”。虽然我希望大多数靠送货为生的人——hashtag无语（SMH）——
would know it more as a number sign. In the States it's usually called the number sign or the pound sign. In the UK it's often called a hash mark, I think more because of the way it looks than anything else. This is Keith Houston. He's the author of a book called Shady Characters, the secret life of punctuation symbols and other typographical marks. It's got a whole chapter on this symbol. And it has a lot of other random uses as well. It's used in chess to represent a move that results in checkmate. In proofreading, if you see a hash symbol,
会更多地把它当作一个数字符号来认识。在美国，它通常被称为数字符号或磅号。在英国，它通常被称为“hash mark”，我想这更多是因为它的外观而不是别的什么。这是基斯·休斯顿。他是《隐秘的符号：标点符号和其他排版符号的秘密生活》一书的作者。书中有一整章都在讲这个符号。它还有许多其他随机的用途。它在国际象棋中用来表示导致将死的走法。在校对中，如果你看到一个井号，
this means a space should be inserted here. It's used on Swedish maps to mean a lumber yard. Hash, pound, number sign, lumber yard, whatever you wanna call it, however you wanna use it. The symbol traces back to ancient Rome. So in Rome, the term Libra Pondo meant a pound in weight. So the word Libra, like the constellation means scales or balances, and Pondo comes from the very penderi, which means to weigh. Libra Pondo, and these two names were interchangeable, so Romans referred to this weight measurement as a Libra or a Pondo. So the word Libra was often abbreviated as Lb.
这就意味着这里应该插入一个空格。它在瑞典地图上用来表示木材厂。Hash、pound、number sign、lumber yard，无论你想怎么称呼它，无论你想怎么使用它。这个符号可以追溯到古罗马。在罗马，术语“Libra Pondo”意为重量为一磅。因此，“Libra”这个词，就像星座名字一样，意味着天平或秤，而“Pondo”源自动词“pendere”，意思是称重。“Libra Pondo”，这两个名称是可以互换的，所以罗马人将这种重量测量称为Libra或Pondo。因此，“Libra”这个词经常被缩写为Lb。
Lowercase L, lowercase B, which of course we still use. So if you see 5 Lb, you mean 5 Libra or 5 pounds in the Latin sense. This is also why British currency, the pound, is represented by a stylized L for Libra. So the abbreviation LB becomes a thing. And oftentimes it was drawn with a little bar across the tops of both letters, just to show that the L and the B were connected. Scribes, our writers, got a bit careless,
小写的l，小写的b，当然我们现在还在使用。所以如果你看到5 Lb，你的意思是5 Libra或者拉丁意义上的5磅。这也是为什么英国货币“英镑”用一个风格化的L（代表Libra）来表示。因此，缩写LB成了一种常见做法。通常情况下，人们会在两个字母顶部的横跨处画上一小道横杠，只是为了表明L和b是连在一起的。抄写员，也就是我们的书写员，变得有些粗心，
so they'd write faster and faster and faster, so you join the L to the B and then maybe the pen doesn't leave the paper before it does the little bar across the top. And so this seems to have given rise to the pound symbol. Or hash mark or lumber yard. Over time, the symbol's meaning started to bifurcate. It was used like LB for the unit pound
所以他们写得越来越快，于是你把L和b连起来，然后可能在画顶部的那条小横杠之前，笔都没有离开纸面。这似乎就催生了磅号。或者说hash mark，或者木材厂。随着时间的推移，这个符号的含义开始分化。它像LB一样用于表示重量单位磅，
and it also started to be used as a number sign. It had a lot of various uses. But it was important enough to wind up on tight writer keyboards, which is kind of the key thing, it's the thing that a symbol had to do in order to survive. Because symbols that didn't make it onto the typewriter, keyboard got pretty unpopular, like the intero-bang, or the pill-crow, or the manicule, it's poor things. Fast forward to 1963, the invention of the touch-tone telephone.
并且它也开始被用作数字符号。它有许多不同的用途。但它足够重要，最终得以登上打字机键盘，这可以说是关键所在，这是一个符号要想生存下去必须做到的事情。因为那些未能进入打字机键盘的符号变得很不受欢迎，比如疑问感叹号（interrobang）、分节符（pilcrow）或手形指示符号（manicule），这些可怜的小东西。快进到1963年，双音多频电话（touch-tone telephone）的发明。
Hi, this is the bell system's new touch-tone diaries. The touch-tone phone used buttons instead of a rotary wheel, so unlike previous phones, the numbers didn't have to be arranged in a circle on the dial anymore. Bell Laboratories, a research subsidiary of AT&T, experimented with a few different designs for the telephone keypad. They tried arranging the numbers in two rows of five, in a circle, and a cross, and a step pattern. But they ended up arranging the numbers one through nine in a three by three grid, and they put
嗨，这是贝尔系统的全新双音多频电话。双音多频电话使用的是按键而不是旋转拨号盘，所以与以前的电话不同，数字不再需要在拨号盘上排成一个圆形。作为AT&T的研究子公司，贝尔实验室（Bell Laboratories）为电话键盘试验了几种不同的设计。他们尝试将数字排成两行，每行五个，排成圆形，排成十字形，或者阶梯状。但最终他们将1到9的数字排成了一个3乘3的网格，并把
zero alone in the bottom center. Years later, in 1968, they figured why not add keys to either side of the zero. This would make the keypad into a nice even rectangle and give users a few more options on the phone menu. To repeat these options, press the start key. Because unlike rotary phones, touch-tone phones allow you to continue to dial after the connection has been made. So you could punch in extensions and navigate automated menus.
0单独放在底部中央。几年后的1968年，他们想，为什么不在0的两侧也加上按键呢。这将使键盘变成一个漂亮均匀的长方形，并为用户在电话菜单中提供更多选项。要重复这些选项，请按星号键。因为与旋转式电话不同，双音多频电话允许你在接通电话后继续拨号。所以你可以输入分机号并导航自动化菜单。
For account information, press one for all other questions. Press two. Originally, Bell Labs wanted pretty shapes on the two extra buttons. They had made prototype phones that had a five-pointed star and a diamond on either side of the zero. But an engineer named Doug Kerr would have none of this diamond and five-point star business. Because by that time a new thing had come into the picture, the possibility of customers dialing directly from their phones into a computer for such things as checking bank balances or validating their credit cards or what have you.
要获取账户信息，请按1；所有其他问题，请按2。最初，贝尔实验室希望在这两个额外的按钮上有漂亮的形状。他们制作了原型电话，在0的两侧分别有一个五角星和一个菱形。但一位名叫道格·克尔（Doug Kerr）的工程师坚决不同意这种菱形和五角星的鬼把戏。因为当时有了一项新事物进入大众视野，即客户可以直接从手机拨号到计算机中，用于诸如检查银行余额、验证信用卡或诸如此类的事情。
Doug Kerr wanted to make sure that the two new symbols would be ones a computer could recognize. One that appeared on a keyboard and were part of the computer's vocabulary. So there would be no uncertainty about how a certain button would be recorded in the data that went into the computer. Bell Labs was pretty set on their star and diamond idea. So the compromise was an asterisk for the star and a pound for the diamond because, you know, the center kind of looked diamond like, I guess. And for a second AT&T was like, can we at least call it a diamond? There's no reasonable reason to call that symbol diamond.
道格·克尔想要确保这两个新符号是计算机能够识别的符号。一个是出现在键盘上并成为计算机词汇一部分的符号。这样就不会对某个按钮在进入计算机的数据中如何被记录产生任何不确定性。贝尔实验室对他们的星星和菱形想法相当坚持。所以折中方案是，用星号代表星星，用井号代表菱形，因为，你知道的，它的中心看起来有点像菱形，我猜吧。有一会儿，AT&T甚至在想：我们至少能叫它菱形吗？没有任何合理的理由把那个符号叫做菱形！
It's not a diamond at all! AT&T didn't know what to call this button in their manuals, and this led to the creation of what some people, including Keith Houston, consider the symbol's official name. The oxothorpe. The octathorpe. One day I was out with my engineering partner, and we got to talking about it and thought maybe we should come up with a new name. This is Lauren Aspland. He worked in marketing for AT&T during the time.
它一点也不像菱形！AT&T不知道在手册中该怎么称呼这个按钮，这导致了某些人（包括基斯·休斯顿）所认为的该符号官方名称的诞生。Oxothorpe。Octathorpe（八角符号/井号）。有一天我和我的工程搭档外出，我们开始谈论这个，并认为也许我们应该想出一个新名字。这是劳伦·阿斯普兰（Lauren Aspland）。他当时在AT&T从事营销工作。
He and his engineering partner looked at the symbol and saw that it had eight lines sticking out of it. So we'll put the word Octo in there and then just out of fit air we just said well we'll put the word FERP, PH, ERP in there too because that sounds kind of Greekish and give it some stature. They called it an octo-thirp, but that morphed into octo-thorp, which rumor has it came about because someone at Bell Labs changed the name to turn it into a tribute to Olympic athlete Jim Thorpe. But no one really knows.
他和他的工程伙伴看着这个符号，发现它有八条线突出来。所以我们在里面加上“Octo”这个词，然后凭空加了“FERP”、“PH”、“ERP”这些词，因为听起来有点希腊风味，而且显得有分量。他们把它叫做 octo-thirp，但后来演变成 octo-thorp，有传言说这是因为贝尔实验室有人改了名字，为了向奥运会运动员吉姆·索普（Jim Thorpe）致敬。但没人真正知道。
G is a proper to spell it, octo-thorp, rather than thirp, there is no proper. Doug calls it an octa-thurpe. Lauren calls it an octo-thurpe. But octo-thorpe seems to have the most widespread use. Though its use is not widely spread. And originally the only reason Octo-thurpe ever caught on within Bell Labs was because engineers thought it was a funny joke. The manufacturer, Western Electric, totally hated that name and pretty much killed it in
正确的拼写是 octo-thorp，而不是 thirp，其实并没有绝对的对错。道格叫它 octa-thurpe。劳伦叫它 octo-thurpe。但 octo-thorpe 似乎使用最广泛。尽管它的使用并不算太普及。起初，octo-thurpe 在贝尔实验室流行起来的唯一原因，是因为工程师们觉得这是一个有趣的笑话。制造商西方电气公司非常讨厌这个名字，并在
the 70s. But today, for a lot of type of fishing autos, Octo Thorpe is the sign's real name. In typographic books, Octo Thorpe is the name used. You might think of it as a technical term. Typographic nerds like Keith Love It because it feels the most neutral and official. But in choosing this symbol, whatever it's called, Doug Kerr and the other Bell Labs engineers really understood that we would be using telephones
70年代基本上将其废弃了。但今天，对于很多排版爱好者来说，Octo Thorpe 才是这个符号的真正名字。在排版书籍中，使用的是 Octo Thorpe 这个名字。你可能会认为这是一个技术术语。排版迷们喜欢 Keith Love，因为它让人感觉最中立、最官方。但在选择这个符号时，无论它叫什么，道格·克尔和其他贝尔实验室的工程师确实明白，我们将使用电话
to communicate with computers. And this is exactly the same reason why Chris Messina chose to use this symbol back in that tweet in 2007. At the time, we had blackberries, we had no keya phones, and these are hardware-based keyboards. But we need something that works in the mobile world And we need something that works over SMS because that's the way that I'm gonna be publishing to Twitter Which left Chris only two choices, the star or the pound?
来与计算机进行通信。这与克里斯·墨西拿在 2007 年的那条推文中选择使用这个符号的原因完全相同。当时，我们有黑莓手机，我们没有诺基亚手机，这些都是基于硬件的键盘。但我们需要一个能在移动世界中使用的东西，我们需要一个能通过短信（SMS）工作的的东西，因为这就是我要发布到 Twitter 的方式。这使得克里斯只有两个选择：星号还是井号？
The pound symbol, the artthorpe, whatever It's probably one of the most dense symbols and so when you're reading a sentence or you're reading a tweet, it stands out And so you see hashtags on billboards and the highway, on promotional materials, on other social media platforms, on protest signs, in your annoying friends' conversations. I'm just gonna show my dentist hashtag, bling, hashtag, dental care,
井号，artthorpe，随便什么。它可能是密度最高的符号之一，所以当你阅读一个句子或阅读一条推文时，它会脱颖而出。因此，你在广告牌、高速公路、宣传材料、其他社交平台、抗议标语、以及你那些讨厌的朋友的谈话中都能看到井号。我只是要向我的牙医展示 hashtag，bling，hashtag，牙齿护理，
hashtag, cavity free, hashtag. That's how we do. And this is all probably gonna sound so dated in like five years, or two years, or maybe a few months. Hearing hashtag out loud is gonna sound like someone reading a telegram. Mr. Gower Cable, you need years, or maybe a few months. Hearing Hashtag out loud is going to sound like someone reading a telegram. Mr. Gower Cable, you need cash, stop. My office instructed to advance to up to $25,000.
hashtag，无蛀牙，hashtag。我们就是这样做的。这一切在五年、两年或几个月后听起来可能会非常过时。大声说出 hashtag 听起来就像有人在读电报。戈尔先生，您需要电报，停。我的办公室指示提前最多 25,000 美元。
He, Ha, and Mary Christmas, Sam Wayne Wright. In a telegram, as on Twitter, our speech changed to accommodate the machines. The Hashtag is a way of changing our language to be more computer friendly. And what we're needing to do is actually invert the paradigm where the computers become more friendly to humans. So we're probably not going to be using hashtags the way Twitter uses hashtags forever. But this won't mean the end of the symbol itself.
他、哈，还有圣诞快乐，萨姆·韦恩赖特。在电报中，就像在 Twitter 上一样，我们的说话方式发生了变化，以适应机器。Hashtag 是改变我们的语言以使其对计算机更友好的方式。我们需要做的是颠覆这种模式，让计算机对人类变得更友好。所以我们可能不会永远像 Twitter 那样使用 hashtag。但这并不意味着符号本身的终结。
It started out on paper, but then it leaped to type writers, computers, and phones, and it seems like it's probably going to stick around. Whatever we decide to call it. Ashtag Octathorp, Ashtag Octathurp, Ashtag Pound, Ashtag Number Sign, Ashtag Lumberyard, Ashtag Tic-Tac-Tow, Ashtag Musical Sharp if you're really lazy. Part 1 of 99% of visible was produced this week by Joe Rosenberg, and part 2 by Avery Trouffman. On the Interro Bang story, Mix and Tech production by Shereef Yusif with music by Sean
它始于纸张，但随后跃升至打字机、计算机和手机，而且它似乎会一直保留下来。无论我们决定叫它什么：Ashtag Octathorp、Ashtag Octathurp、Ashtag Pound、Ashtag Number Sign、Ashtag Lumberyard、Ashtag Tic-Tac-Toe，如果你真的很懒，还可以叫 Ashtag Musical Sharp。本周的 99% Invisible 第一部分由乔·罗森伯格制作，第二部分由埃弗里·特劳夫曼制作。关于 Interro Bang 的故事，混合与技术制作由谢里夫·尤西夫完成，音乐由肖恩制作
Rial. Music in the Octa Thorpe episode by Melodium, Lollatone, Keegan DuWitt, and a few others. There's a full list on the site. The rest of the 99Pi team is Digital Director Kurt Colstead, senior producer Katie Mingle, senior editor Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lee, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective
里尔。Octa Thorpe 插曲中的音乐由 Melodium、Lollatone、Keegan DuWitt 以及其他一些人创作。网站上有完整列表。99Pi 团队的其他成员包括数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）、资深制作人凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）、资深编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、维维安·李（Vivian Lee）、塔伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7KLW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的 Radio Row。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。99% Invisible 是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由
of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find more at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook, you can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or work. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want all the old episodes plus designing stories that we don't even talk about on the podcast, go to 99PI.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立集体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解更多信息。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论，您可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars 以及节目 @99PI。我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也有账号。但如果您想要所有旧节目以及我们在播客中甚至没有讨论过的设计故事，请访问 99PI.org。来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。